the hamptons is a beautiful getaway for
the rich and famous in the summer
but in the winter it's a quaint village
inhabited by a tight-knit community
among the many eateries here is finn
mccool's a family restaurant which is
unfortunately dying
gordon ramsay is here to breathe new
life into it i know it's winter but
god you think there'd be somebody around
here this place is desolate there's
hardly anybody around
oh come on
there he goes
i'm the owner of finn mccool's family
restaurant an irish pub my young love
said to me
i was a police officer i worked for the
southampton town police department i was
there uh over 20 years already this
should be moved over here a little bit
and i retired and i was retired for uh
12 hours eight of which i slept and then
we opened up finn mccool's family
restaurant we are a family i mean that's
what we're all about
that's who we wanted to cater to both of
my sons work here full-time and jason
he's a bar manager
he's happy at the bar everything's good
my problems are more my brother
i'm gonna kick you into teeth i swear
i'll help you out get out of here you
need me to do i would definitely not
recommend working with family no it's a
pain in the ass you're an ass i swear to
christ you are
i'm very good at what i do i don't know
if my dad and my brother could survive
without me being the kitchen go away
there you go
he is an arrogant little bastard
i developed the name chef shortcut for
him because he just cuts corners he'll
deep fried bacon and they come out like
pig's tails it's like chewing a bacon
ball it's absurd i'm in charge of the
food and i have my name behind it i know
what can work and what won't work he
could be pretty cocky at times yourself
holy crap
there's times where he's very
disrespectful all right look at me no i
swear i won't look at you to the point
where i i can't believe the things that
he says what do you need it for i can
throw it at you brian jason uh butt
heads a lot
he comes pretty close to blows
well tell him to stay the [ __ ] out of
the kitchen jason you know tries to talk
to him brian's all his ears closed down
no no you don't know what you're talking
about whatever grow off this isn't
nursery school i don't really give a
[ __ ] about their feelings it would be
great to have somebody of chef ramsay's
caliber come in and show brian that he's
not right
i don't need help cooking
[Music]
before i would just leave the kitchen
and let him go on his way but the
business is
it's floundering
there's no way of anybody knowing
that it was a restaurant you know we put
signs on the windows and things of that
nature but
still haven't gotten a sign out front i
mean we just don't have any money
buddy is in debt somewhere in the
hundreds of thousands
my father's invested everything he has
into this business his whole life as a
cop and and retirement and pension and
this and that it's gone i absolutely
worry about buddy's health
[Music]
i worry a lot about his health
it's not my boat and i don't want to go
down with it i understand why he thinks
he can be the way he is if it doesn't
work
he it scares me to think how much not
only does he lose how much everybody
loses we need this for our families and
more in every night going to bed you can
be able to pay this mortgage
and try to just barely scrape by and
make it happen i can't describe to you
how stressful that is
i can't
[Music]
here i'm at finra calls they have a
family that are in crisis and uh bloody
hell it looks like a funeral parlor from
the outside not a restaurant
oh
a grin
[Music]
hello
hi
how are you buddy mazzio good to see you
my first impressions of chef ramsay were
that he's an intense man i didn't know
if he was gonna be
some kind of a bastard or an eagle man
or something like that is my son jason
jason nice to see you nice to meet you
good hello this is carol nice to see you
my first impression of gordon i think
he's adorable i would love to get my
hands on gordon
this is my daughter-in-law melissa
melissa jason's wife my son brian chef
are you well the first time i saw him
when he came in i was definitely a
little skeptical i do my own thing back
here and i'm very content with it
so let's start with carol what's the
problem
we have problems with staff
we have problems with brian
okay he's a bit arrogant and
a lot arrogant because i i say what
needs to be said and you peter people
don't want to hear it
too bad
that's not true we're here to make money
yeah and if you're not going to do your
job get out i'm sorry brian but it's
it's stems from him because
he won't listen to buddy
an example like valentine's day i wanted
him to do a nice valentine's day menu he
didn't see the need for it because we're
an irish puppy you didn't think anybody
could come in for an irish pub for
valentine's day
about it
[Music]
to have come up with it weeks before
because you are the head chef we don't
want every time
i'm cool
oh boy right now
i'm hungry i want to taste the food and
let's meet after shall we
i was pretty nervous i wonder what he's
gonna see i wonder if we're gonna get
really blasted you know
there's our lunch menu thank you i'm
like i'm about to serve chef ramsay like
this is so cool the clams are they fresh
clams um
honestly it's frozen
i'll start with the uh
thin spring roll please good choice
thank you can i go for the salmon as
well please darling for main course i'll
have a shepherd's pie please i think
okay thank you melissa you're welcome
[Music]
i i want to see you and ramsay uh chug
chug yeah yeah oh smoke
tuck them in the bed
goodnight
[Laughter]
i'm a very confident person and i've
been in the kitchen for a long time i'm
almost positive we'll get a good review
when you get a family business right it
goes on for generations and here
it doesn't feel like a family-run
business at all
pubs are full of atmosphere fun
it's got tweed neck curtains like you're
going to visit your granny
weird
here you are spring rolls with coleman's
mustard well
go
[Music]
it's a very strange bizarre looking
spring roll
[Music]
are they poppy on the menu um people
really like them
no doubt half the customers are drunk
this is the tough half hour of my life
not a big hit you're like no
brian's in the kitchen like wondering
i'm just like
nope
are you kidding me
he really thought that i was gonna walk
back there and be like he loved it you
know he he wants you to come work for
from come on
let me try that one
let me get you some clean silverware
thank you go on
and what's the stuff we please uh
melissa on top is a balsamic reduction
he likes to use that a lot he likes that
yes he does he on everything he puts a
little drizzle on a little
thank you you're welcome
always the sign of a very insecure chef
when he macerates everything in pulse
we're gonna go
look at
this
ah
horrible
it doesn't taste like salmon at all off
there does my shepherds probably have
any balsamic vinegar
no good lovely i don't even think he
likes the water
he said um will my shepherd's pie have
any balsamic vinegar on it i said i can
assure you it will not
do i
do i dare
i don't like to come off conceited or
cocky i'm very good at what i do i know
the back of the house very well i've
done everything that's out there
[Music]
let's try that one
[Music]
enjoy thank you you're welcome
it's just a big ball of grease
[Music]
just very very greasy
that's disgusting
oh no
oh my god something made it made him
sick
i don't know if he went in the bathroom
and threw up but he ran and he ran into
the map
[Music]
after suffering through the best finn
mccool's has to offer it's time for
gordon to have a little chat with the
chef
clearly we've got issues
when a chef can't make a [ __ ]
shepherd's pie it worries me my shepherd
pie was taught to me by you know
somebody who learned it from somebody
who went to ireland you know it's an
american irish pie it tasted like cough
mixture
and then the salmon
what on earth was going on there the
salmon dish that i put out to them
always had rave reviews from everybody
that's had you could've eaten tuna from
a can
it was that overcooked
was that you at your best that was me
doing what i do is i cook for you i'd
imagine the way that i would have cooked
for somebody i would come in tomorrow
night that i don't know every day you
have to give it your best shot
he has no idea what he's talking about
so whatever he has to tell me i don't
really care
[Music]
for a restaurant to survive in the
hamptons
it not only needs the vacation business
in the summer
but a loyal local following all year
round especially in the winter
i'm at the fire department what better
place to actually find out what is finn
mccall's really about
good morning guys
how are you
hi sir how are you good to see you how
are you i'm rick schultz and i'm the
great fear nice to see you very wandy
thank you welcome to the neighborhood
yeah very happy to be here tell me about
fema calls
uh
a lot of fried food ready yeah fried
food a lot maybe a little too much on
the fried food what i'd like you to do
um if you could come back
and come and have dinner there as my
guess
um
these guys here have got their fingers
on the pulse in the community and you've
got to look after the locals what better
locals to keep on your side the firemen
piss them off you've pissed the whole
town off
[Music]
after inviting the firemen to dinner
gordon decides to do a quick
investigation of the kitchen
[Music]
this shelf when was the last time
somebody actually wiped it down
[Music]
you eat that
[Music]
canned artichokes this is lethal
what what what is that
so god knows how old was the shepherd's
pie that i had lunch time
please tell me
people do not eat that
cooked chicken wings
raw food
against cooked food
what is that
oh
oh for god's sake
kitchen nightmare this is a kitchen
disaster
[Music]
there is one clean thing in here
[Music]
disappointed by the state of the kitchen
gordon is questioning the family's
commitment to their restaurant
okay i went through the fridges and i
was pretty disgusted brian
you need to seriously pay a lot more
respect to what you're doing and the
first thing you're going to do this
morning whether we like it or not yeah
all of us
is we're gonna clean
i was a little offended i always
consider myself to have a pretty clean
kitchen me you and you we're gonna clean
the kitchen yeah everywhere yes it
pissed me off i don't dirty that kitchen
i don't cook in that kitchen so i don't
want to go into his kitchen and clean it
all out off soaked and we get all these
changed and then
quite frankly i thought we were pretty
clean clean
it was uh it was frustrating and uh
definitely embarrassing but uh even your
friends he had some gloves on he was
cleaning i think that was more
impressive than anything to see him
being as hands-on as he was guys
underneath there
what a difference
[Music]
the kitchen has been cleaned just in
time for dinner
if only there were some customers
when we're struggling like we are now
it'll drive you crazy
why don't more locals you know come
maybe they've come here and had a bad
experience and didn't want to come back
[Music]
thankfully the local firemen have
decided to take gordon up on his
invitation
good to see you
good to see you it's now crucial that
chef brian take advantage of this
opportunity to impress the local fireman
what is that nachos
[ __ ]
nachos
[Music]
when was the last time we got fresh
vegetables in the house
last summer last summer
now i just cringe when i see them that's
all
i developed the name chef shortcut for
him because he just cuts corners
well hey brian big clam casserole
did you buy the clown it's frozen
you can't get fresh hands
yes
i have a big problem with gordon hanging
over me watching every step when i'm
doing something leave me alone and let
me do it
45 minutes into dinner service and the
firemen are still waiting for their food
75 of the time i go back into the
kitchen my brother's on a cell phone i
say how are you cooking not even looking
at what you're doing how could you
possibly be cooking and doing this when
you're sitting there chatting on your
cell phone when the firemen finally do
get served
they're not impressed thank you is there
something wrong it's not hot enough
uh brian
three seconds please
so guys this is brian the chef yes have
any of you met no these guys are your
locals
start off with your pie
please how was it it wasn't warm enough
the flounder was frozen wasn't very
flaky
since it was an irish place i went with
the popcorn beef sandwich we had but it
seemed to be very dry
he's a volunteer fireman i do this for a
living and for somebody to critique me
who doesn't even really do it for a
living
you know you want to tell him to shut up
thank you okay
cheers you can bet your butt they won't
be coming back so i was just like
i don't see how this is going to work
after feeling the heat of the firemen
brian and sous chef francis get back to
work under the watchful eye of gordon
who can't believe what he sees
[Music]
francis francis francis
francis that he's death as a [ __ ] bat
darthurst
he took off the floor put in the fryer
and then back in the sauce
yeah well the fryer is gonna uh
it's going to
take anything that'll come off the floor
it's going to if it fell on the floor
yeah
you put it back in the fryer right in
the front and that cleans it yeah
cleaned it
sterilize it sterilize it yeah well
[ __ ] me
sterilized it
[Music]
didn't work i dropped the wing on the
floor picked up and stuck the bag in the
fryer again
[Applause]
we're trying to keep everything
consistent but
some things
get messed up every now and then
what the [ __ ] were you thinking
oh my god
i've never ever ever seen anything quite
extraordinary as that he serves food off
the floor and serves the customer
oh my god no
[Applause]
[Music]
it's day three and knowing full well
that finn mccool's is the lifeblood of
the maseo family gordon is about to find
out how desperate the business really is
if there was no significant improvement
how long could you afford to stay open
for we're in we're in trouble right now
you know we're probably i would say five
thousand dollars a week or four thousand
dollars a week under what we need to
survive
under yeah so 20 grand a month
yeah
just recently took a little personal
loan from a friend and i pay him back
you know that kind of thing just to get
us through this
dreadful period here you know i don't
sleep well on people money you know it's
not it's not what i do
i haven't taken a check yet
you haven't paid yourself yet on the
business i get my checks in the seat get
a stack of them have a great look
but the boys get paid buddy yeah
everybody else does but these are
and you can't you can't catch them
no
i've never lost anything i've always
been
relatively successful
buddies basically put everything into
this place by this place not doing as
good as he dreamed is just breaking him
um difficult having two sons in the
business do they know the situation
you're in
i think jason understands more brian's
out on an island a little bit um if
brian wasn't my son
i'd have fired him
ready
if this doesn't work and it does close
what will the boys do
this is
this is my you know
our entire family
lives their lives i can i can feel it
you know my sons eat their dinner
because of fema cools you know their
houses are warm because of fema cools
and to think that
we would close it would be catastrophic
with a full understanding of the
financial picture gordon turns his
attention to the food beginning with
teaching brian how to make a proper
shepherd's pie
right give me the large tray
that we put in the fridge to set and
we'll put the potatoes on there put it
in the oven for five minutes to have
them come to your place and show you
what you should be doing the right way
put some cheese on there grill it and
then get them to taste it okay yeah to
be honest with you it made me laugh a
little drain off that fat
that's why i got upset with you on the
other day that the tell me
add that into the mints into the bowl
to think that we are fortunate enough to
be schooled by a man like chef ramsay
well you'd be a fool not to uh not to
jump on this
let's go in the dining room shall we
okay
so i just want you to uh have a little
taste of fin mccall's shepherd's pie yes
rich ground beef
[Music]
this is good
ours originally certainly had more much
more of a brown sauce to it and it was
fatty
then gordon brought out brian's old
shepherd's pie to compare
[Music]
this is with the before and after that's
horrible look at that
i thought our shepherd's pie was halfway
decent it wasn't it was terrible our new
shepherd's pie it's fantastic this is
very very good
i come out looking like the [ __ ] of
the family
he was uh tremendously pissed off
[Music]
after being humiliated brian goes to the
bar
hey cheers guys good to see you guys
thanks for coming out
and that's happening
i got to take it easy today take it easy
people see brian has taken advantage of
me all his life if he wasn't my son i'd
have fired his ass out of here
i know your buddies are outside but i
don't expect you to be running back and
forth every time to go talk to your
friends
seriously
okay i'm serious all right i'm not
kidding i said all right
enough
i lost get out of here let me do my job
stay back here and do your job
chill out
nobody wants to get yelled at that
they're not doing their job properly i'm
not going to stick around for it why are
you standing right there
i definitely once again felt like a
little kid getting yelled at i'm i'm
[ __ ] standing right here i'm doing
what i got to do watch him out watch him
get out of here
i didn't even want to be here anymore i
don't know if i wanted to be in the
kitchen anymore never mind here
[ __ ] off
you know that
i'm done working here
[Music]
that was horrible he's stubborn as a
mule you know he's just absolutely
stubborn he just disappears
[Music]
brian's departure has left the
restaurant without a chef and buddy is
forced to run the kitchen spring rolls
can you soup thank you what's up there
bob salad good so you're aware of that
you've done that before of you i'm
thinking jesus christ look at me i know
the hell i'm doing back here what is
this uh fascinating isn't it
i'm glad you find that difficult to read
there was eight tickets on the board
yeah i didn't even know what tickets
were up buddy buddy buddy no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no but i have to take some mama man
it looks like a crock of [ __ ] hey no
start again
[Music]
buddy you happy with that bacon there
like that
looks [ __ ] looks like [ __ ] come on big
boy standards
that's better service please
did it top to the bun
sorry tap to the bun top to the bun we
only sent half an hour
there was no bun on that let's put it on
straight away we'll argue after
buddy veggies please some surprise
is that other shepherd's five or six
coming for them
but for [ __ ] sake
buddy can't even find a [ __ ] doily
let alone cook a flounder sweating
dripping now smashing plates his own
plates no wonder brian's a cranky [ __ ]
[Music]
it's day four and brian's loyalty to his
family brings him back to work
you get a renewed respect for what brian
has to go through it's tough job it's
tough and a mozzarella stick going
i gained a lot more respect for my
brother and all these times that i'm
hard on him and i get angry at him and
we fight about stuff and
i couldn't do what he does
with a new appreciation for brian gordon
decides to spend some one-on-one time
with him
i knew you were an angry chef frustrated
pissed off with your dad i didn't know
what you had on your shoulders before i
walked in here
there's parts of me that
feel for you in a way that i
i've started to understand what's on
your shoulders
when you get pissed and frustrated who'd
you talk to who do you open up to
i'm not gonna write to my little one
have you thought about quitting and
setting up elsewhere
yeah
i can't tell you
how important your role is enough i've
probably faded out a little bit in
stepping up my game and to where it used
to be so i i might have lost some of the
passion which is which is sad to say
that because i didn't think that but now
it's kind of over my eyes a little bit
about that you've got to handle it a
different way
in a way that you become
the responsible one
and [ __ ] focus
if you've got the security of your food
and you make this place rock i promise
you that's going to give you stability
to run this business
for the next 20 years okay thank you
good man
chef ramsay definitely kicked me in the
ass and got me excited to do what i'm
doing
while gordon has been dealing with the
family's issues his design team has been
sprucing up the restaurant in
anticipation of the relaunch
[Music]
oh my gosh you walked in and you felt
like you were in your home it was it was
so comfortable it's bigger huh holy
moses
oh look at the booths god warmer yeah
wow i'm in shock
i'm never lost for words
you know this is overwhelming gorgeous
for buddy this was his big dream it was
very cool seeing that just look on his
face when we walked in there wow i'm
happy
we've been given a gift now it's our job
to make this work and we certainly will
it's beautiful holy moses this is so
exciting i sure framed he asked us to
hang outside for a little bit
something you've always always wanted
never had
welcome
to finn mccall's yes
lovely
wow established 2006 family restaurant
is that beautiful that is gorgeous huh
that is a beautiful sign right there you
can see that from 100 meters right i
didn't know he would go to that extent
and really go that extra mile for us you
can't miss this it's tough to put into
words how much that means to me and and
the rest of my family buddy happy with
the color holy moses look at it
it was very emotional we were all
getting teary-eyed and the four of us
were just
in awe
at least when you drive by now you know
what it is amen i'm thankful as an owner
of a restaurant
and i'm also thankful as a dad
although finn mccool's has a new sign
and a new look it's the food that brings
in the customers the first thing i did
was got rid of thirds of the menu
because a you know the majority it was
frozen b wasn't fresh what's the point
in having on there whatever comes out of
here has my name on it and i don't want
to mess this up you've got to move with
the seasons get rid of the dark heavy
sauces and line up a little bit gordon's
new menu of contemporary pub food
includes the guinness pop burger and
gordon's own family recipe for
shepherd's pie and then the fireman's
chicken chef ramsay dumped the fried
foods
they're gone and to give the restaurant
a new energy and to take some pressure
off brian in the kitchen gordon has
introduced tableside service tonight
we're gonna be roasting a chicken we
roasted in the kitchen i'm gonna cut it
tableside don't be nervous about it i
can see it on your face already
yep don't it creates a buzz in the
dining room and it creates a bit of an
excitement
ready let's go okay you and i in the
kitchen let's go
listen we've been through a lot in this
last week it's been amazing you know
we've learned a lot we've seen a lot of
things that we've done wrong we've
taught a lot of things and how to do
things right we can come out of the
blocks today and people can leave here
saying oh my god what a place this is
this is huge this is this is a grand
opening smile make people feel have fun
let's kick this in the ass make this
happen yeah that's all do it from top to
bottom all right anybody have any
questions
communicate five minutes go compose
go compose hurry up
the news of gordon ramsay's new menu has
spread through the town
and the restaurant is fully booked for
relaunch all right come on in gordon
also persuaded the firemen to give finn
mccools another chance don't look so
nervous just smile even when it's going
wrong smile okay
this table right here i can buy what i
chair five in a high chair this is their
one big last chance of getting this
thing right welcome to finn mccolls my
name is melissa and i'll be your
waitress tonight this is our big chance
the whole community is coming here you
want a big one or a regular i'm filled
with excitement i can't wait for this
this is what you live for tonight's
gonna be great brian can i please put a
ticket in
i'm thinking all right well i gotta have
this i gotta have this and then i didn't
have time to think of what i gotta have
anymore because the tickets started
coming would you like a booth
come on in we opened up the floodgates
what's all this food doing up here
where's this going oh man
[Music]
it's a huge night at finn mccool's the
locals have come out and the place is
packed
tonight is without question a wonderful
opportunity for the mazzeo family
but if it doesn't go well it could be a
good buy party instead of a relaunch
tonight
we have a lot of wonderful things on
there
i don't want to see any sloppy [ __ ]
bowls i want nice clean bowls nice
cooked food and just
pride tonight all about [ __ ] pride
yeah definitely
this is a big big big night tonight when
i first arrived at finla calls the
restaurant had torn the family apart now
we've got a new menu new decor a nice
attitude and they've got to run it as a
business we have got one big chance and
they have got to get it right
adding to the pressure on the kitchen is
the presence of the local food critic
this critic represents dan's paper it's
a local paper so you know
word gets out on the street new menu new
decor hey
yeah we got it come on there we go here
we go
this is not a [ __ ] around this food
critic in here you know that we'll be on
it we're reviewing the restaurant they
want a good review they should give us a
tape that's true
go on i know rice pudding that one vat
is gone is that it uh yes i'm start
smiling you've lost your smile
chef is telling me you're losing your
smile you're losing your smile how the
hell could i smile right now they've all
been in there 1 hour 45 minutes i need
the table back yes absolutely i'm like
oh my gosh just please don't yell at me
right now because i'll cry and then i'm
gonna have to go over my table and toss
a salad while i'm crying
i forgot my scissors
brian do you have this caesar dressing
of the week they should have it okay
[Music]
keep an eye on the salad for me i'm
gonna run and grab it myself
it was just
it was nerve-wracking
i'm running around the chicken with head
cut off where is the caesar dressing i'm
gonna go to the table without the
dressing where is the dress you got it i
know i was a little nervous there
dressing right here my bad my man
while the kitchen is overwhelmed the
customers are restless i would think
within over an hour we would have our
food on the table
while people in the dining room are
waiting a long time for their
an food the fire chief is yet to be
seated i think we ordered before then
they're a little overcrowded for the
fire coach
every place important tonight every
oyster every play every customer yes be
really careful because this is extremely
hot it was uh it was frustrating for
sure and uh definitely embarrassing
pretty much a three-ring circus broke
out
can i have half a lemon rather than sell
it on there please yeah just a half a
lemon cut in half uh give me one second
i'm sorry i'm getting pissed now yeah
let's go with chef ramsay screaming at
me don't get [ __ ] pissed with me i
definitely once again felt like a little
kid getting yelled at
i've seen you work faster than this yes
it's a new menu but you can move faster
yeah let's go
two pot pies of stew and a shepherd pie
come on buddy come on come on come on
come on yummy
that's the oyster there you go thank you
you're welcome enjoy
stay in control briana buddy that's for
your chicken
[Music]
buddy is nervous about going around and
carving up those chickens tonight almost
the one that got away come on come on
come on come on while brian tries to
keep the kitchen under control
jason is busy putting out fires in the
dining room i apologize he's working on
a brand new menu with a pack dining room
all at once but if they can't handle the
new menu then they can't cook with food
grand opening if they can't get the food
could have just started giving little
brother some [ __ ] so hey prove them
wrong come on
i would love a review
we're seriously in the [ __ ] now the
bar's completely blocked and jason's all
over the place he's now getting [ __ ]
from customers we've got to turn those
tables this is the critical point of
this restaurant they've got to turn this
wake up and speed up shaft honest
opinion should i tell people at the bar
they might not eat tonight
we're going we're going i've seen you yo
i've seen you work first on this yeah
you got to [ __ ] ignite that fire yeah
come on
60 plus people here that are pissed off
at the chief for getting them here
tonight and it ain't right it was tough
it was tough people were getting angry
i'm pissed i'm leaving
what chef ramsay saw was was a dining
room that was a disaster
[Music]
it was a horror show an absolute harsh
show
[Music]
come on brian got to step up now my man
just honest opinion should i tell people
at the bar they might not eat tonight
our restaurant was
overwhelming
with the dining room in disarray and the
kitchen in chaos gordon steps in come
here
you've got to take control your kitchen
now let's look at it this way we have to
work i mean really dig deep to get these
locals back on our side so don't
disintegrate
and the quicker you get to speed with
what's going on here this whole thing's
going to start gelling a lot quicker i
got a little disheartened at first how
it was turning out but chef friends had
wanted me to be able to show that i
could do it give it some fire let's go
[Music]
the family begins to get it together and
the food is once again leaving the
kitchen
but they face another critical test
the food critic i highly recommend the
chicken or the shepherd's pie tonight
[Music]
perfect every customer's your critic but
this one
is a food critic yeah
i'm i'm sorry about the delay the
shepherd's pie is excellent any problems
just throw a glass at someone yeah don't
worry
why don't i take this
but i take this too i can take those
okay
[Music]
be very careful
not to touch that
[Music]
and i brought little side dishes for
everybody
[Music]
[Music]
he's table she thought this shepherd's
bite is delicious
beautiful
now this is where this pub starts to
make money it's turning tables for the
second time the atmosphere is electric
no matter how much money you got in
hamptons you can't buy an atmosphere
like this extraordinary we can put these
two soups out here
we're on it come on bobby yes yes i said
i was doing this i told you i was gonna
pack the place yes yes 24 hours hello
the word spread and every [ __ ] turned
up with their dog do me a favor yes stay
for a while
the dinner service ends successfully
customers are leaving satisfied and the
family proved that they can make it work
at least for one night
[Music]
14 years of
working in decent places and crappy
places and
trying to get everything i can to have
somebody like that show you
awesome
it's you know it's what i wanted to do
for a long time and i just faded away
you know just came in and went through
the motions
and then for him to come in
it would tell me that i needed to get
back into it and
he actually did he you know made me feel
like uh i wanted to cook again
[Music]
no no no guys let me tell you what i saw
and this is the goddamnest truth i saw a
family come together there was a buzz
everybody felt it you know and we were a
family again the first
and foremost important thing to think
about tomorrow do not stop supporting
each other because you've got a great
family and when it works it's beautiful
goodnight chef
gordon ramsay refers to me as a chef it
blows my mind don't you stop big boy yes
hey cocky [ __ ] ah he's put us to the
test it was very rewarding to hear chef
tell us what a good job we did
smile you yes
yes yes
detective my ass are you sure
we appreciate what he did all the work
that he did didn't fall on deaf ears i
saw a family come together i was proud
really proud
they're a great dad and you've got a
heart of gold and two great sons
cheers take care thank you
[Applause]
you know sometimes doing these can be a
right pain in the ass i have to say this
one was a joy because this family now
are united and they deserve to be
successful
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
two months later and finn mccool's is on
its way to establishing itself as a fun
happening family restaurant clams are
just delicious really good welcome to
finn mccool's this is the greatest thing
in the world greatest thing is to have
it the shepherd's pie is the talk of the
town and the pride of the local
community brian and jason have become
quite the team both striving for
excellence and supporting each other you
got it yeah you sure beat it i love my
brother to death uh no question as for
buddy he finally cashed his first
paycheck
and at last irish eyes are smiling i
have
two sons that are phenomenal i have a
great staff that's what that's what it's
about that's why we're here this is what
we planned for i love it